all right let's start our second session
of the
um of the morning
and the next speaker is luis chamong uh
talking about uh graphone neural
networks
yeah thank you thank you very much so
before i begin let me just acknowledge
that actually the work that i'm going to
present is uh led by luana louise at
penn together with my uh
old phd advisor uh my
former phd advisor i don't know old he
might not appreciate that uh former phd
advisor alejandro rivera
so let me jump right in with the main
question that i want to tackle today
which is what happens if we train a
graph neural network on the wrong graph
so to first make sense of this question
and then answer it i will sort of go
through this road web of uh going from
convolutional neural networks to graph
neural networks then to graph neural
networks and then back
so let me start by explaining what i
mean by this question right in the first
place and by revisiting how we get from
convolutional neural networks to graph
neural networks
now the idea of convolutional neural
networks are these architectures that
are quite well suited for processing
image or audio data because they display
several desirable properties right on
these domains such as stability
translational variants good properties
good priors on on features adapted to
this underlying problem geometries
and a lot of these properties arise due
to
properties of the convolution on these
sort of regular domains right but
sometimes
we find ourselves facing data that do
not live on these regular domains and
that's the case for example with
network data that we find in
applications such as
resource allocation in wireless
communication networks or uh
decentralized controllers for for
flocking for swarms of agents or even in
recommendation systems where you can
think of user preferences as living on a
similarity graph right between the users
now just as feed forward neural networks
are not really well suited for uh
studying images for for processing data
image data regular convolutional neural
network are not really well suited in
this context which brings us to you know
this idea of graph convolution now graph
convolution are defined essentially by
replacing the regular convolution stride
by one that is adapted to the underlying
network so for example we would use the
adjacency matrix or the laplacian of the
network in order to induce a linear
operation that we will call the stride
of our convolution and we can define the
convolution just as we did always by you
know aggregating these different uh
strides throughout
throughout our data multiple strides
throughout the data
now for certain particular choices of
graphs we even recover the classical
convolution so you know in a sense you
can think of graph convolutions as sort
of a generalization of convolutions
regular convolutions to this network
settings
so how do we get from convolutional
neural networks to graph neural networks
we just replace
graph
regular convolutions by graph
convolutions and that's that's the only
thing we do
now the
reason why graph convolutions are
attractive is because in a certain way
they induce features that are adapted to
the underlying network of our problem
right in the similar way that you know
regular convolutions induce these few
key features in
in the regular case now the role of the
coefficient of the network is then to
select and combine these features right
in order to
to achieve the task of interest by
filtering essentially the eigen modes
that are induced by this linear operator
that we defined as the stride of our of
our convolution
now depending on the gap between these
three these
uh these features this this spectral
feature graph spectral features they
might be easier or harder to to
discriminate right on on the underlying
uh in for the underlying task which
shows really the importance of a
speaking over choosing that graph that
induces this convolution properly for
for the specific um
application that we're trying to solve
here
now in practice there are many reasons
for us to believe that we will actually
choose the wrong graph
and the reason for that is
the first one is is sort of because this
graph is typically estimated from data
right so we will for example use a
covariance matrix that we estimate from
data so in that case we actually get the
wrong graph because we don't have access
to the real one but there are even cases
where the application itself does not
allow the application does not allow
itself
to have a specific graph for example if
the graph is dynamic which is what
happens in decentralized control
problems where the network topology
actually changes as the agents are
moving
or because the graph is only partially
available because it's part of a large
scale network that either due to
computational or cost issues we don't
have access to all of it
so going back to the question that i
asked in the beginning motivated by sort
of this discussion of uh you know trying
to find the correct graph in the sense
so you know what happens if we train on
the wrong graph
or or better yet like more specifically
what happens if we
train a neural network a graph neural
network using one graph and then test on
one on a different graph right or by
changing by keeping the coefficient
freezing the coefficients but using a
different graph convolution let's say
now in general what happens who knows
because these graphs are completely
random by each other there's not much we
can say
but in all the applications that i
mentioned one one feature of them is
that these graphs they share certain
types of structural properties right
they are similar in a certain way that
they look the same even though they are
different and the way we're gonna
talk about looking the same is in terms
of density of homomorphisms right so an
automorphism is just an an embedding
let's say of a graph of a smaller graph
that we call a motif into these larger
graphs and we'll just count essentially
the proportion of these motifs that will
appear in these graphs right they sort
of this density of homomorphisms sort of
tell us what is the probability that
neighborhoods of of nodes look like that
right and we will do that for different
types of motifs
this is exactly how we get from graphs
to graphos right
so the reason for that is because
uh even though the definition of a
graphone is simply a bounded symmetric
kernel so we can think of this as a
continuous adjacency matrix let's say
right the reason why we care about this
is because these are actually limit
objects of increasing graphs that
converge in density of ammonite
which means that this limit object
actually imposes a lot of structural
properties on the graphs that come
before and depending on the graph that
we use we'll see graphs that have
different structural properties
right this is one way of interpreting
graphones but graphs are also
interesting because we can sort of
revert that that uh that property by
essentially looking uh at graphons as
models for generating graphs right we
can think of them as continuous
stochastic block models essentially
and
by sampling graphs from the graphones we
obtain graphs that belong to this
sequence let's say that share this
property of having of converging in this
density of homogeneous so graphs that
look the same in the sense of having
similar let's say
properties
this property of density
given that we we have this idea of
graphon we can do the exact same thing
we did for graph convolutions
with now with the graphone so we'll
define a graphone convolution by
defining a linear operator based on the
graphone right which we will call the
stride over of our convolution and that
linear operator will define that stride
will define a new form of convolution
which is simply the aggregation of
different applications of that linear
operator to our to our input
based on that we can go through the
exact same exercise again of building
graphone neural networks by simply
replacing the graph convolution by this
graph evolution now the input of the
graphon neural network is a continuous
signal
right rather than a sampled one and the
interesting thing here is that what we
build in the end this graph phone neural
network is in a sense the
um
the limit object of a sequence of
growing graph neural networks that
converge in this uh that
so that the graph of the convolutions
converge in this density of morpheus and
you know the input signal coverage in a
sense in l2 we can make this uh
definition formal you can look at the
paper by essentially working on this
this this product topology between these
two
now this idea that the graphone
neural network comes as a
a limit object for these graph neural
networks allows us to essentially go
back to our question that we had in the
beginning
to graph neural networks as what happens
when they go yes
so um the examples that you get so so
the graphs are for the
you know dense dense case but exactly
examples that you gave don't seem to be
there so some of them are
so the
recommendation system that's a dense
that's a dense problem
the
flocking is
uh probably not because that's well it
depends a little bit on the
communication region but it's true that
there are essentially it's the nearest
neighbor graph so it's probably not in
the the third example that i gave the
wireless communication one that depends
on the topology it could be dense or it
could not that's actually one of the
points in the end that's a very good
question
the
what happens in the sparse case that's
something that is ongoing work
definitely
yeah so
um so we can go back essentially and use
the graphone as a way to connect these
graphs that we are really care about
right about the training and the test
and what we do is simply say well we
will say that we will compare the
outputs of these neural networks but we
will put them essentially we will
connect them by saying that you know
there are
graph neural networks that converge the
same graph on your element
the graphs are sampled from the same
graph
and this gives us a way to control the
graphone gives us a way to control the
structural properties of those graphs so
that we can say something about about
them the second thing that is
interesting if you remember i mentioned
that the graphone is a
is the limit object for graphs that
converge in um
density of homomorphism that gives us
also a handle on spectral property of
these graphs right because if you think
in terms
of cycles for example right cycle
density of homomorphisms in terms of
cycles are essentially traces
of the of powers of the
um of the adjacency matrix so they give
us sort of controls over the spectrum as
well as controls over over the
properties of this and these are the
prop and this type of
um
these type of results in terms of
spectrum is what allows us to connect
let's say
smoothness properties of this limit
objects to
difference in the outputs between these
networks and that's exactly what we do
in our result where we connect the
smoothness of the graph on and of the
input signal as well as the smoothness
of the polynomials that are induced by
the coefficients of the filters in the
in the neural network two differences in
the output of two graph neural networks
that essentially come from the same
graphone family right and they can have
different sizes but we just care about
the minimum sizes of the two of them
and essentially this is the bound that
we obtain
so i'll zoom in a little bit to explain
a little bit where the different
components come from the first one is
just a component that doesn't depend on
the dna at all it's a component that
depends on the input signal the
difference between the input signals of
those
neural networks it goes to zero as we
sample more from this continuous signal
that we are assuming that we are
sampling the inputs from
now the two other components they depend
directly on the architecture and on the
parameters of the neural network the
first part here
is
a part that we call the transferable
energy of the error right because it's a
part that goes to zero as the graphs
grow right as the graphs that we are
training and testing on become larger it
essentially depends on the how smooth
your graphone model is which tells you
you know how similar the graphs that
you're going to sample from your farm
and also how smooth the filters
underlying the neural networks actually
are as well
the second term here is a part that we
call the non-transferable energy because
it doesn't depend on the number of nodes
of the graph and we can actually trade
off between these two types of of uh of
errors by this uh bound parameter tau
which is essentially the bandwidth uh
bandwidth parameter right so it controls
directly the non-transferable term by
essentially determining what we are
calling the non-transferable band right
and it also affects the
transferable energy through this
discriminability parameter so if you
remember in the beginning i was
mentioning that these filters are going
to the role of the neural network is
going to be to combine the different
you know components of uh
that are induced by the graph these
different um
features right and this is essentially a
measure of probably screaming at all
these features up which is how many of
them there are in the past then but also
how separated they are right so we can
make now we can decrease tao to decrease
the non-transferable energy
but at the potential cost of possible
possibly you know increasing the um
the transferable energy now yes
this is when you say we can trade off
this is not something you don't work
with
no no the method is fixed this is a this
is a proof this is only from the booth
exactly
that's exactly where i was going now so
we could optimize this balance for tau
right but this discriminability
parameter depends on the graph on itself
so it depends on
spectral properties so actually you can
optimize for tao but it's a problem
specific guarantee that you need right
asymptotically you can take it out to
zero and and remove this bound but the
rate at which you should do that depends
on spectral properties that's a very
good question thank you
um
okay so just uh wrap up since uh this
very short quick ride throughout uh a
lot of things uh i try to give you so i
try to give you an idea of where graph
neural networks come from as
generalization of convolutional neural
networks for this sort of network uh
applications right and
the question that we had to ask was you
know what happens if we train the
bracket or network on a different graph
than we wanted to test in practice
right
but in order to answer that question we
essentially built
limit objects of these graph
convolutions and graph neural networks
which were the graphone convolution and
graphone neural networks and got this
result that tells us that you know gnns
are transferable between
uh between different graphs in practice
and in training as long as you know the
graphs are large enough
the spectral features are well separated
for the feature test that you have which
will also make the dnn filters being
less sharp because they need to separate
between less complicated features and uh
a question that we have been working on
is the one that actually peter asked in
the beginning which is you know
graphones they're actually good models
for dance graphs right because there are
node exchangeable models for node
example graph so what can we say in the
sparse gate essentially this is a
question that can we do better in that
case or or worse and what are the
properties as well like this tau this
bandwidth property that actually tell us
how to control the error in that case
uh if you want to know more there is a
new rectangle from last year about this
that you can check out or
go directly to my website
uh or luana's website which who is
actually the lead on on this project
thank you very much
thank you um we have time for maybe one
or two questions while the next speaker
sets up
are they discretization difference
so y1 and y2 are the outputs of the
filters to because they might have
different sizes they are essentially
zero folder interpolation so we that
norm is in l2
so they're not they're for different
discretizations of the of the same
signal but processed through different
data
random sampling process
you can do random sampling from the
deterministic graph no no you can you
can do it this is the new work that
actually luana is doing today i didn't
talk about it but you actually get a
slightly better rate even in that case
because the output of the output are
have different sizes but this is not
they are not related to the graph on
themselves just the graphs not the
output
so the input is just sampled in l2 so
that's not the problem there
you can you can match them
they will converge anyway as long as you
take more samples it's doable
but it's not what i talked about today
thank you
let's thank louise again
so
yeah the next talk is by spencer frey on
self training
converts with learning to strong
learners